what is up everybody it's Anna Mac and
welcome to another installment of the
week's best anime videos where you can
come to catch up with all the great
content that you might have missed in
the past week before we get started I
just want to say merry Christmas to all
of you guys who are celebrating today
I'm actually Orthodox Christian and we
go by the old julian calendar so that
means that my Christmas doesn't come
till January seventh and that also means
that I get to do my Christmas shopping
with all the Boxing Day savings and also
if you're celebrating Hanukkah Happy
Hanukkah to you and if you're
celebrating another holiday have a
wonderful holiday as always all the
links are in the description and if you
have a recommendation leave it in the
comments and remember the next week
we're doing a special year's best anime
videos so that's going to be pretty epic
this week we saw the release of two
massive and highly anticipated teaser
trailers one for code geass season 3 and
another one for attack on titan season 2
the attack on titan trailer was actually
an official release it was posted on
Funimation with subtitles and it looks
great if you've been reading the attack
on titan manga you will recognize some
of the things in the trailer and the
animation looks amazing the fight scenes
look really good so yeah it was highly
anticipated and finally it's here
definitely worth a watch the code geass
teaser trailer was more or bootleg
release and included some exclusive
scenes that were only shown at the
10-year anniversary event a few weeks
ago and now they were finally leaked
online however the quality is not that
good but come on it's code geass season
3 it's still pretty awesome if you want
to know more about the code geass
trailer last night actually uploaded a
detailed analysis of it so i'll leave
the link in the description if you want
to check that out on thursday mystique
ranexa uploaded a baby-gender-reveal
video in which he reveals the gender of
the baby that he and his wife jess are
expecting in a few months and so
drumroll please
in the room the baby is I can't tell you
guys just go to the video and check it
out for yourself it's awesome now in
this video missed he also talks about
the fact that his channel has been
getting less views lately which is also
a problem of course because he has to
support a family now and he was
wondering whether the YouTube glitch has
any part in this and you know what
actually I've always gotten
notifications for Misty's videos but for
this baby-gender-reveal video I did not
receive a notification the only way I
found out about it was over Twitter so
from my personal experience I can
definitely say that something is wrong
with YouTube notifications and that
could be part of the reason why misty
hasn't been getting as many views as he
usually gets as I mentioned in previous
episodes big youtubers like misty depend
on YouTube for their livelihood so these
glitches are really messing with them
and I really hope they figure it out
soon and if you want to support misty go
watch his videos go support his channel
a few weeks ago on twitter aki dearest
said that she would be making more a
fact and analysis based anime videos
from now on and this week she released a
video about the legacy of Studio Ghibli
that was just amazing I really loved
everything about this video it was so
well done so well edited it brought back
so many great memories about Studio
Ghibli films and it featured some
amazing music like the perfect music
soundtrack to bring out all the emotions
I was feeling at the time I absolutely
love Studio Ghibli films and when I'm
feeling down I still like to watch a
cheaply film and it always makes me feel
better well maybe not a grave of the
fireflies but it's still a great film
anyway I definitely recommend checking
out okies video it was really really
good just yesterday Joey the anime man
released a video called 12 days of anime
cringe myths a Christmas parody song in
this video Joey and a whole bunch of
other friends that he collaborated with
basically made a funny anime version of
the twelve days of Christmas song where
they poked fun at a whole bunch of anime
tropes and cliches if you're an anime
fan you will definitely find this video
entertaining and funny and it really
features some really cool people some
really cool youtubers it features a key
singing and yeah it was just a great
experience definitely give it a watch
back on Thursday we streamed the fifth
episode of r & cafe and in this one we
were talking about the
diverse genres of anime and once again
the stream was such a great success
thanks to all the people that showed up
in the chat and had a great discussion
with us I really appreciate it we've
formed a great community around ran cafe
already and I just want to thank you
guys again that means a lot to all of us
there will be a new episode of r & cafe
coming up this coming thursday at five
p.m. eastern standard time and in this
one we're going to be talking about the
best and the worst of 2016 in the world
of anime we're going to have a brand-new
special guest for this one Lou talks
anime along with the usual suspects
Mackle not all day anime bread from
brent's fandoms and maybe simply Rose
can make it back if she's not busy we'll
see and we'll let you know yesterday on
Saturday we also had a special code
geass theory stream where we discussed
all the cool theories the craziest
theories about code geass season three
and it was just a great discussion so
many of you guys showed up so many of
you watched and we're gonna make a great
video based on these theories that we
discuss so I'm really looking forward to
it and because this stream was such a
success I think we're gonna do more of
them in the future I think we're gonna
do a stream sort of brainstorming
discussion stream every time we're
making a big Theory video to make sure
that we could we're making the best
video possible based on all the feedback
we get from you guys if you're
interested in something like that
definitely let us know in the comments
because your support means a lot and if
you're interested we'd love to keep
doing these and my favorite AMV this
week was a gintama AMV called empty
lives by youtuber known as I Neil this
amv youtuber was actually recommended to
me in the comments by calming on the lad
and I checked him out and I saw this MV
and I thought it was great so thank you
comment allowed for the recommendation
and definitely check out this and the it
features really artistic sort of retro
visuals combined with dubstep music of
all things and it's really an
interesting mix it's unique its artistic
definitely give it a watch and that's it
for this week guys if you like these
videos be sure to LIKE be sure to
subscribe and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]